oh yeah it's finally happening my
friends the DEA is loosening up about
weed well at least it's loosening up
about weed in the lab the DEA just made
it easier for scientists to get their
hands on more of the stickiest of the
icky up until now scientists in the US
could only get their date from one
supply one and that would be the growers
at the University of Mississippi of all
places and they have really only put out
one straight which is THC dominant now
the DEA will allow more growers to get
in the game and more growers will mean
not only more weed but better weed that
is more strains that aren't just
full-tilt THC what scientists are
actually more interested in is a
compound in cannabis called CBD that
shows the most promise for medicinal use
for treating things like epilepsy and
psychological disorders problem is the
DEA isn't doing anything about funding
these new grow operations and given the
security required it could get wildly
expensive for universities that want in
that and marijuana remains a Schedule
one drug under strict control it'll
still be hard for researchers to get
permission to study weed in the first
place so making more weed available to
scientists may be a small step but hey
we're talking about the DEA here take
what you can get man take what you can
get